E
POLITICAL FALLOUT, NEWT GINGRICH
AND MARK MEADOWS.
BUT FIRST, BIDEN'S BODY BAG.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
FOR THE PAST WEEK, BIDEN AND HIS
TEAM HAS SPUN OVER AND OVER THAT
THE EVACUATION IS GOING WELL.
WELL, TODAY, WE SAW THE TRUTH.
THIS WAS ALL TOTAL CRAP.
THIS WAS A TOTAL CATASTROPHE.
AND IF YOU AND YOUR TEAM,
MR. PRESIDENT, CANNOT HANDLE
THIS MISSION, WHY SHOULD WE
TRUST YOU TO HANDLE ANY MISSION?
OUR ENEMIES KNOW WE ARE BEING
LED BY A BAND OF INCOMPETENCE,
AND NONE OF THEM ARE SHAKING IN
THEIR BOOTS FROM THIS BIDEN
PROMISED.
>> TO THOSE WHO CARRIED OUT THIS
ATTACK, KNOW THIS.
WE WILL NOT FORGIVE.
WE WILL NOT FORGET.
WE WILL HUNT YOU DOWN AND MAKE
YOU PAY.
>> Laura: THE FACT IS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS
HANDPICKED MILITARY LEADERS HAVE
FAILED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY FAILED TO BRING AND BUILD
AN AFGHAN ARMY TO WITHSTAND THE
TALIBAN.
THEY FAILED TO ORGANIZE A
WITHDRAWAL THAT DIDN'T DEVOLVE
INTO TOTAL CHAOS.
AND THEY FAILED TO FIRST EXTRACT
OF AMERICANS STILL IN HARM'S WAY
AND INSTEAD, THEY PRIORITIZED
AFGHAN NATIONALS.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS STILL REMAIN IN
AFGHANISTAN.
HOW MANY MORE MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM MIGHT DIE BECAUSE
BLINKEN, MILLEY, AND THE REST
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN JOINED
THE MILITARY TO SERVE AND
PROTECT THEIR COUNTRY, BUT NOW
THEY ARE FORCED TO SERVE UNDER
LEADERS WHO COULDN'T RUN A
SCHOOL CROSSWALK.
ALL AMERICANS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
WITHDRAWN WEEKS AGO, NOT IN THE
LAST MOMENTS.
ONCE THEY CREATED CHAOS ALL
AROUND THE AIRPORTS, IT CREATED
IMPOSSIBLE SITUATIONS, ONE THAT
ALLOWED ISIS MILITANTS TO MURDER
OUR SOLDIERS.
JUST LIKE JOE BIDEN CREATED A
MAGNET FOR ILLEGALS AND THE
CARTELS OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
HIS PLAN CREATED A MAGNET FOR
TERRORISTS AT THE AIRPORT IN
KABUL.
>> WE EXPECT THOSE ATTACKS TO
CONTINUE AND WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BE
PREPARED FOR THOSE ATTACKS.
THAT INCLUDES REACHING OUT TO
THE TALIBAN, WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE OUTER SECURITY
COURT AROUND THE AIRFIELD TO
MAKE SURE THEY KNOW WHAT WE
EXPECT THEM TO DO TO PROTECT US.
>> Laura: IS HE EVEN LISTENING
TO HOW INSANE HE SOUNDS?
HE IS THE HEAD OF CENTCOM.
WE ARE RELYING ON THE PEOPLE WHO
WE HAVE BEEN AT WAR WITH FOR THE
LAST 20 YEARS FOR PROTECTION AND
SAFE PASSAGE?
NOW WE ARE LETTING THEM PLAY TSA
FOR US IN KABUL?
OF COURSE, THAT'S NOT EVEN THE
WORST PART.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY GAVE
THEIR TALIBAN COUNTERPARTS A
LIST OF AMERICANS IN COUNTRY AND
A LIST OF AFGHANS OKAYED FOR
EVACUATION.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN OCCASIONS
WHEN OUR MILITARY HAS CONTACTED
THEIR MILITARY COUNTERPARTS IN
THE TALIBAN AND SAID "WE WANT
YOU TO LET THAT BUS OR THAT
GROUP THROUGH."
I CAN'T TELL YOU WITH ANY
CERTITUDE THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
BEEN A LIST OF NAMES -- MAY HAVE
BEEN, BUT I KNOW OF NO --
DOESN'T MEAN IT DIDN'T EXIST, WE
ARE JUST COUNTING ON THEIR SELF
INTEREST TO CONTINUE TO GENERATE
THEIR ACTIVITIES.
AND IT'S IN THEIR SELF-INTEREST
THAT WE LEAVE WHEN WE SAID, AND
THAT WE GET AS MANY PEOPLE OUT
AS WE CAN.
>> Laura: IT'S ACTUALLY
SCARIER HEARING THAT THE SECOND
TIME AROUND, BY THE WAY.
I ONLY HEARD IT ONCE, THAT WAS
THE SECOND TIME, IT'S
TERRIFYING.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
ENCOURAGING THOUSANDS OF
DESPERATE AFGHANIS TO FLOCK TO
THAT AIRPORT, OF COURSE, JUST AN
IDIOTIC ENDEAVOR.
WE ARE SEEING IT PLAY OUT AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
DESPERATE MIGRANTS, THEY ARE
RUSHING IN.
AND IT IS JUST PAIN AND
SUFFERING CAUSED ALONG THE WAY.
THESE ARE PURELY POLITICAL
CALCULATIONS THAT BIDEN'S TEAM
HAS MADE.
THEY WANTED MILLIONS OF MIGRANTS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER, THEY GOT
THEM, AND NOW THEY WANT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AFGHAN REFUGEES
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, AND
WE ARE ON TRACK TO GET THAT
NUMBER, AS WELL.
MY FRIENDS, THEY CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE THIS.
THIS CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN.
JOE BIDEN HAS PROVED HIMSELF TO
BE COMPLETELY INCOMPETENT.
A SINGLE AMERICAN SERVICE MAN OR
WOMAN SHOULD NOT DIE UNDER THE
REGIME THAT THEY'VE CREATED.
IN THE MILITARY LEADERS, FROM
MILLEY TO THE HEAD OF CENTRAL
COMMAND TO WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
OUR SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, LLOYD
AUSTIN, NONE OF THEM SHOULD BE
STILL IN THEIR POSITIONS, NONE
OF THEM.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS SOMETHING WE
NEED IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND REMEMBER EARLIER THIS WEEK,
WE HEARD BIDEN AND HIS TEAM SAY
"OH, NOW IS NOT THE TIME" --
ANTONY BLINKEN, "NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
CLOSED WOULD.
NO, NOW IS THE TIME TO ASK THE